you don't think putin is intimidated by
biden i i don't believe so you don't
think so i mean why would he be if he
were intimidated by biden he wouldn't be
he wouldn't be doing what he's doing
today i mean he sounds like a pretty
intimidating guy what he said to peter
ducey yesterday right the question was
asked did you hear what he said to peter
ducey if you want to pull that up matter
of fact just play it david if you can
turn it over so we can show the video
uh when peter ducey asked the question
if he can make that bigger somehow uh
control plus and then audio would be
very helpful tyler most people can't
yeah go back to you know the political
liability ahead of the midterms
that's a great asset
more
inflation what a stupid sound [ __ ]
so how bad is that by the way is that is
that like adam to you you hear that does
that do anything to you or you're like i
can't believe he said that that's not a
pro or a con to me i mean it's like okay
good for you got it i mean trump has
said worse on a hot mic loudly so
but this is the thing though you know
you voted for biden a lot of people who
voted for biden i'm not making
assumptions about your reasons but a lot
of people said it's because trump's not
civil enough he doesn't act presidential
he says stuff like that and so when
biden says the same thing
you know i think
it should be condemned the same way but
it's not really me if he had a track
record of doing that to reporters and
calling the you know media fake news and
literally encouraging people to fight
each other yeah okay yes let's
lampoon on on biden he kind of was like
i mean who doesn't talk like that ever i
mean if someone pisses you off
okay if someone pisses you off like
regardless of who you are
but you know what would happen if let's
say if governor desantis he has a press
conference today and if he said
something like that to a reporter the
media would go insane like you might not
i'm not saying you would but i wouldn't
but but you know it would be like a
nuclear meltdown from cnn and from you
know i i hear what you're saying you
know fool me once you know shame on you
if only twice if this starts to being a
reoccurring theme that biden is just
just found what happened last week as
well yeah but most of the time he's
calling you like a foul-mouthed pony
face dog like can i tell you something
can i use anything
like that i mean
let me ask you who seems uh that they're
angrier trump or biden
right now no no no no just period who's
go to it and go to trump and then they
would ask him questions no no was he
angry was he competitive was he a troll
because biking just seems angry i i will
give you that yeah he seems angry he
seems like he's bitter i'm like buddy
nobody was fighting something
i think trump is in a whole another
atmosphere but clearly
biden's poll numbers are are
in in the gutter yeah he's not exactly
having a great week or a great month or
a great way to start the year
so he's a little feisty you know what
i'd show a little backbone and call
somebody a son i'm a [ __ ] i'm okay with
that uh sleepy joke yeah wake up i will
i will tell you what happened yesterday
right afterwards so peter ducey goes on
fox and he tells him how it was and what
happened because he didn't know what he
said back to him he couldn't hear him he
thought he said sob says no they said
the whole thing and then you know
they're talking about that would be a
great title for a book you know stupid
son of a can you imagine that title four
book that'd be a great title for a book
but he says later on biden called him
biden called him and he says nothing
yeah he says i just got a call from
biden on my cell
and he said hey nothing personal pal
that's what he said he said nothing i do
too i like that to be honest with you
the fact that he called up the right
people and said hey buddy he said
nothing personal and then he said
afterwards he said uh president biden
you just have to know i'm gonna ask the
questions that others are not willing to
ask you and biden said and you should so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you